scp-682 was once at the mercy of the
liminal Abyss known as the back rooms
but now the hard to destroy reptile had
become a master of the back rooms after
absorbing the essence of the skeleton
Queen along with several other powerful
backrooms entities
scp-682 had become powerful enough to
create its own level of the back rooms
level 682 if you cannot beat the back
rooms become the back rooms in its
latest adapted form 682 was able to
command the lesser entities of the back
rooms such as clumps death moths and
Hounds these entities were now at the
beck and call of 682 and could be
deployed at moments notice to Savage
trespassers on 682's level while it was
nearly unfathomable to believe that any
human Explorer could survive the long
journey from Level 0 to level 682
Challengers would soon arrive to attempt
to snatch the proverbial Crown from
682's reptilian head the death of the
skeleton Queen had upset the balance of
the back rooms and now there were
countless other supernatural beings that
wanted a taste of the scrappy newcomer
the first two Warriors to arrive were
the infamous spear using humanoids
entity 74 Argos and entity 720 tiny
other than a shared weapon of choice and
a mutual hatred for scp-682 these two
entities had little in common but the
sting of their previous defeats at the
claws of their hated rival had compelled
the two to make their way to level 682
and faced the lizard once more Argos
bellowed as he entered into the
devastated Wasteland of level 682 he had
appeared first accompanied by a
specially trained retinue of human
soldiers in tactical gear the eyes of
Argos each one wielded a lesser replica
of their Immortal Leader's signature
Spear and all were ready for battle
faced with these Intruders all scp-682
could do was laugh wickedly its own Army
of hostile entities stood at attention
leering at the humans entity 74. Argos
scp-682 greeted its visitor even without
eyes in that swollen head of yours you
must see that you cannot win this Argos
roared that 682 was a sinner and his
judgment was here Argos pointed his
Spear and the eyes of Argos charge
towards 682 who in turn raised a claw
and signaled its own forces to meet the
eyes on the field of combat level 682 of
the back rooms was now a battlefield
human soldiers and entities were
clashing in pinched Warfare Argos broke
through the front lines and turned his
spear on 682 the reptile merely grinned
through all of its teeth as argos's
spear with was deflected effortlessly
off its hide Argo struck again and again
but it seemed that the eyeless giant had
totally underestimated 682's new form
this was not going to be the same fight
as the previous time the two had met
with the level of strength that the
reptile had amassed it might not even be
anything that could be considered a
fight at least not if it remained a
one-on-one battle fortunately for Argos
the other of the back room's spear Duo
was about to make a splash literally a
gateway to level 7 the Endless Ocean
opened above the battlefield causing an
Untold quantity of water to flow into
the war zone of level 682 it was chaos
as both Argos and 682's minions were
swept up in the current and drowned out
Argos was frustrated at the sudden loss
of his army but 682 couldn't care less
about what happened to backrooms
entities that had temporarily bought
themselves a bit more time in existence
by pledging loyalty to their reptile
Master it was after all only a matter of
time before 682 had gotten sick of them
and destroyed the miserable entities on
a whim serious contenders only your
entrance was sinful Bargo spat towards
tiny as the Rushing Water submerged him
my entrance like everything I do was
perfect tiny scoffed now are you going
to Aid in my revenge against this
loathsome Beast are you going to be
sanctimonious as usual the spear Duo
acknowledged each other and putting
aside their differences in a temporary
Alliance though for 682 in an attempt to
overwhelm the hard to destroy reptile
the tips of both Spears collided with
682 and managed to push the creature a
short distance across the now submerged
landscape of its level in retaliation
682 traded its claws for a number of
flexible tentacles that were able to
push off the ground and Propel the level
Master towards its two to adversaries it
grappled Argos with its long flexible
arms and swung him against the solid
surface of the ground the eyeless
Warrior countered by stabbing one of
682's tentacles but the clever reptile
shed the tentacle immediately and
jettison towards tiny the humanoid
attempted to stab 682 but was unable to
hit his Target as his opponent used its
tentacles to grab Tiny's body and
maneuver around him effortlessly
meanwhile Argos was just now coming to
grips with a disadvantage of its own
while on land the sin Hunter was quite
capable of sustaining countless injuries
and regenerating from the damage its
respiratory system had no way to
evacuate the water that had begun to
fill the humanoids lungs though he was
Immortal Argos was drowning even his
unlimited stamina could not prevent his
body from slowing down at this moment
both entities were unable to gain a
significant advantage over 682 moreover
the lack of cohesion between their
tactics was leaving both open to a
counter-attack this was precisely the
kind of opportunity that 682 had been
waiting for while in its prior State the
hard to destroy reptile was only able to
adapt its own physique but now that it
had become one with a portion of the
back rooms it had gained the ability to
adapt its level as well in an instant
682 asserted its control over its domain
and expunged the water from Level 7 back
into the liminal nothingness between
levels while Argos could now stand back
on Solid Ground it was sluggish and
immobilized by the water in its body he
attempted to gag and force the water out
but leaving that kind of opening was a
time that entity 74 didn't have entity
720 came crashing down upon Argos
smothering The Entity having now
immobilized both of its adversaries 682
was quite proud of itself it whipped at
tiny with its fearsome tentacles adding
insult to injury with deep wounds across
the Giant's entire form spear carriers
don't belong on the main stage drawing
from the same Wellspring of power that
allowed it to absorb the skeleton Queen
scp-682 devoured the essence of both
entity 74 and entity 720. just like the
time before the hard to destroy reptile
went one step further than mere
consumption The Reptilian master of
Dimensions assimilated and Incorporated
elements of level 7 and level 10 into
the exponentially growing borders of
level 682 now that it was Victorious
against the two spear-wielding humanoids
682 let out a mighty Roar that echoed
throughout all the remaining levels of
the back rooms the message to all
dimensional rulers on every level was
crystal clear if they didn't come to
level 682 to challenge its Master the
reptile would bring the challenge to
each and every one of them I and the
back rooms and when my kingdom comes I
will be all there is While most of the
entities and humans on the other levels
cowered in fear there were still several
who still wish to stand and fight the
next opponent that would confront
scp-682 in an attempt to slay the
creature was none other than the blue
Knight of level 28 the brightly shining
suit of armor strode into level 682
carrying a raging Storm behind it
hurricane force winds beat down on 682
followed by an unforgiving reign of
lightning bolts the reptile weathered
the storm and struck back with a vicious
bite that crushed the armor of the blue
Knight's arm and part of his chestplate
then 682 turned like a crocodile in a
death roll inflicting even more damage
to the sentient armor with his free
Gauntlet the blue Knight pounded on
682's head bringing down even more
lightning and wind on the reptile your
storm is weak I feel disgusting having
to use my immense power to dispel it yet
again 682 manipulated its level of the
back rooms causing the storm that the
blue Knight had called to be banished
into the void between levels the blue
Knight was aghast the reason he had
always stayed on level 28 was to spare
the humans of more subtle levels from
the wrathful storm clouds that he was
known to create in his moments of
emotional outbursts it was his most
shameful curse and yet 682 had made it
disappear as simply as Morning Mist the
now powerless blue Knight could do
nothing as he too was devoured by 682
his next words were plea for a wish that
could never come true I wish I could
have seen you one more time Sarah like
Argos and Tiny before him the blue
Knight and his corresponding level 28
had become part of 682 now 682 was
starting to get accustomed to the
feeling of devouring levels of the back
rooms The Taste was invigorating and out
of a sense of malicious initiative The
Reptilian entity went on an unplanned
Rampage through the surrounding levels
while it was nothing more than a trivial
test of the incredible power at its
disposal 682 was able to drink in more
of the back room's Essence and soon it
was beginning to reshape the liminal
Abyss itself countless entities were
nothing more than cannon fodder to the
Unstoppable machine of Destruction that
682 had become as foe after foe fell
prey to entity 682 Master of the back
rooms more of the other levels began to
disappear as they were absorbed into
level 682 the reptile was on a violent
spree at this point and could almost
imagine itself back at the foundation
painting the walls with mobile task
force agents and researchers alike in
its friend frenzy
scp-682 found itself once again face to
face with the plush Dino of level 18 the
despised entity 198 who served as a
guide for lost and distressed souls and
at once regarded as cp682 as the most
tormented being in existence even now
the plush Dino's instinct to reach out
to those suffering from terrible anguish
had guided it to the new and improved
682 682 had always disliked 198 and was
especially resentful that it had chosen
to appear now did its presence mean that
deep inside 682 was still suffering from
the scars of its past no I have overcome
that adapted I always do 682 stepped
forward as if to consume its next victim
but a nagging feeling stopped it from
committing to the attack if it were to
Devour the plush Dino there was a
possibility that it would also consume
level 18. a subject of Realm that would
always transform to recreate the
childhood traumas of the Explorer inside
it six 82 had not been afraid to face
its traumatic past during its Journey
Through the earliest layers of the back
rooms but to make the echo of those
painful memories a permanent part of its
form seemed to be a bridge too far
besides what would Jerry think of me
scp-682 caught itself thinking of entity
7 again it was frozen with indecision
unsure whether or not to devour entity
198 on the spot then a sudden blaze of
scorching Flames snapped 682 back to the
present moment this gasp of Inferno
caused the plush Dino to turn tail and
move to a different level of the back
rooms 682 was now surrounded by fire at
some distant level that it had never
seen before on the horizon stood a vast
Army of flaming beings blowing with a
solar light that gave off an
unbelievable amount of heat presiding
above all all others in this militant
fire Army was the apparent leader a
six-armed bright red humanoid whose
Regal features were as imposing as the
Halos of sunflare that adorned his
fingertips this unfathomable being would
soon be 682's latest and thus far
greatest Challenger he was a legend of
the back rooms and the true ruler of the
warlike dimension of level 966 The
Inferno an ancient god whose Relentless
forest fires had chased Lord wormwood
and his tree people to the brink of
Extinction the forge master who pulled
the flame o the golden from the all
Brilliance and made it his source of
power this was rajaharan the golden
Kindle Prince of fires of light o great
Beast of level 682 I rajaran have heard
the tales of your glorious Conquest
throughout the liminal spaces of these
backrooms
I have heard that you hail from the
front rooms and are the uncontested
strongest being from that reality I am
here to answer your summons and per your
request for a challenge see which of us
is the greater the prince of fires moved
his hands and cast forth a merciless
conflagration of Stellar flame 682 was
bathed in the fury of a thousand suns
and felt an unthinkable Rush of pain
unlike even the sword of the Guardian
from back home the fires continued to
lick its form as 682 went berserk and
charged towards the armies of rajaharan
quick as the spark of an ignited flame
rajaharan intercepted 682 and delivered
a punishing kick to the lizard's spine
fire swirled around the prince's limbs
transforming into burning weapons do not
think your quarrel is with my Army the
prince said flatly they are here to
watch rajaran swung all six of his
muscular limbs striking away at 682 with
the Divine weapons held in each 682
cried out in agony swinging a claw back
at the prince I'm leaving a cut across
the Regal beings face the reptile then
stole a page from its Fallen adversaries
and transformed its tail into an
unbreakable spear striking rajaharan
with a swift attack
magnificent rajaharan smiled the battle
raged on for several hours with both
entities taking severe damage and
continuing to fight even as their bodies
were wounded with the sheer force of all
the attacks given and received as it
dragged on rajaharan revealed even
greater reserves of solaric power than
682 could have believed likewise 682's
strength continued to rise as the
reptile acclimated to its ungodly strong
opponent several times 682's body was
burned entirely to Atomic Ash but it was
able to regenerate and continue the
struggle against the prince of fire and
light it was much later when rajaharan
fell the noble golden Kindle had a smile
on his face an eternal acknowledgment
that the opponent he had faced was one
truly worthy of killing him well fought
Lord of 682 I bequeath my Army to you
rule the back rooms in my state as his
Essence burned to Cinders the forces of
level 966 bowed their heads to 682 a
backrooms legend to destroy all back
rooms Legend now go check out scp-018
can the Super Ball defeat scp-682 and
was scp-682 really that hard to kill
after all for even more